[Music]
on this saturday night the climate
conference crisis
why canada is being forced to wrangle
with the richest nations we are fighting
for the survival of humanity will the
world commit to helping poorer countries
move away from fossil fuels america's
record-setting death toll as tens of
millions refused to get vaccinated plus
sight unseen the surge in remote home
buying and how this quebec river was
given the same legal rights as a person
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us with just weeks to go before the
united nations climate summit in
scotland canada is having to do some
heavy lifting our environment minister
has been given the task of corralling
countries to raise a hundred billion
dollars to help more vulnerable nations
tackle climate change as david aiken
reports climate activists are worried
the politicians are all talk and no
action
the stakes could not be higher we are
fighting for the survival of humanity
and that the climate crisis and the
threatening ecocide
are the biggest threat
humanity faces canada's environment
minister agrees
we are facing an existential threat it's
not a question of whether we reduce
greenhouse gas emissions it's about how
we do it wilkinson was in italy meeting
with 40 environment ministers from
around the world preparing for a key
united nations meeting on climate known
as cop 26 to be held in early november
in glasgow scotland the task for cop 26
delegates will be a daunting one agree
on a way to cut global greenhouse gas
emissions by 45 percent by the end of
the decade this is doable the bottom
line is folks that as we stand here
today
we believe we can
make enormous progress in glasgow
moving rapidly towards the new goals
that the science is telling us we must
achieve cop 26 delegates will also be
asked to donate to a 100 billion dollar
fund to help developing nations cope
with the effects of a rapidly changing
climate canada is playing a key role in
establishing that fund germany and
canada were asked to corral the money
in advance of cop we have been spending
a lot of time over the last couple of
months doing that the delivery on 100
billion is going to be vital and that's
why we are putting together a delivery
plan together with our colleagues in the
german and canadian governments
but climate activists are worried all
the talk by politicians will not be
followed by action we are pretending
that they have solutions to the climate
crisis and that they are taking
sufficient action
but we see through their lives and we
see through their blah blah blah and we
are tired of it
some of those activists clashed with
riot police in milan and all of those
activists will likely follow the
politicians to cop 26 in glasgow in
november
david aiken global news ottawa
new research suggests our children face
a dark future of climate change
disasters they'll experience more heat
waves more severe floods and crop
failures than their parents or
grandparents and they'll live in a world
with far fewer types of plants and
animals as evidenced this week when the
u.s declared nearly two dozen species
officially extinct as jackson brosco
reports scientists warned the planet's
biodiversity is at risk
this is one of the last recordings of
the kauai oo bird
these some of the final images of the
ivory built woodpecker species that are
now gone officially declared extinct in
the united states this week we dedicate
our lives to preventing extinction and
so acknowledging that we might have lost
that fight is hard with alarming speed
animals plants and insects are
disappearing from the earth the united
nations reports more than one million
species are on the brink at risk of
being wiped out not just by human
encroachment but by the impacts of
human-made climate change the
biodiversity crisis and the climate
change crisis are highly intertwined for
example climate change is impacting
wildlife
either directly or indirectly and
leading to more extinction
in the last three years 30 percent of
the koalas in australia have perished
due to wildfires and drought
in canada more than 200 species of
animals are today considered at risk the
vancouver island marmot is now one of
the rarest mammals in the world their
natural habitat and hibernation patterns
disrupted by warming weather instead of
pushing for protection one species at a
time we really need to look at
protecting entire landscapes entire
ecosystems conservationists warn
wildlife sanctuaries and protected lands
alone are no longer enough
migratory species like monarch
butterflies are being decimated by a
disruption in the weather patterns they
rely on throughout the seasons it's not
safe to assume any any species is safe
from climate change basically the fate
of all wildlife is in our hands now
understanding the connection between
climate and all life on the planet is an
important first step
without drastic measures to stop the
earth's warming the sights and sounds of
the wild risk being lost forever
jackson proskow global news washington
turning to kova 19 four more people have
died in new brunswick as that province
faces the biggest surge in cases since
the pandemic began today the province
smashed its daily case record reporting
140 new infections health officials say
67 of those cases involve unvaccinated
patients
public safety officers in new brunswick
will be conducting spot checks at face
services this weekend a number of
churches have been the site of recent
public exposures the kova 19 pandemic is
now the deadliest in american history
surpassing the 1918 spanish flu more
than 700 000 people have died from the
virus since march of 2020 as jennifer
johnson reports some extraordinary steps
are being taken to curb case numbers and
save lives
seventy thousand of the last one hundred
thousand coba 19 deaths in the u.s have
been among the unvaccinated lawsuits
over vaccine mandates have reached even
the nation's highest court late friday a
u.s supreme court justice denied new
york city school teachers emergency
request to block a vaccine mandate this
is crazy the teachers many who protested
all month were required to get
vaccinated by september 30 or be placed
on unpaid leave for a year meanwhile
california has become the first state to
require covet 19 vaccines for all school
children although the mandate won't take
effect until the vaccines receive full
federal approval these requirements are
working across the country i think the
evidence is rather overwhelming children
over 12 are already eligible to get the
shot vaccines for five to 11 year olds
could get emergency approval from the
food and drug administration by the end
of october i can't wait i've been
waiting for vaccines for my son that's
the biggest concern we have today is
sending him to school without a vaccine
last month president joe biden ordered a
vaccine mandate for 17 million health
care workers in facilities receiving
federal aid hundreds have quit in
protest it's a personal choice
that i feel
in free america i should have
the the ability to make the choice if
and when i want to take it
many health experts are encouraged after
merck's announcement that its
experimental cover 19 anti-viral pill
cuts deaths and hospitalizations in half
this is a phenomenal result i mean this
is a profound game changer to have an
oral pill
that had this kind of effect the
potential treatment is being compared to
tamiflu which is supposed to be taken
within two days of flu symptoms merck
says it will seek emergency fda approval
soon health canada is also reviewing the
pill the u.s government has already
agreed to buy 1.7 million doses
jennifer johnson global news washington
hundreds of cities across the u.s are
hosting the women's march today it's the
first one for the biden administration
with its site set squarely on abortion
rights
thousands of people headed straight for
the steps of the supreme court women are
demanding continued access to abortion
in a year when conservative lawmakers
and judges have put access on the line
on monday the supreme court will start a
new term justices will consider a
mississippi case that could enable them
to overturn roe versus wade and
dramatically reshape access to abortion
across the u.s
a canadian man suspected of being the
voice of violence in the so-called
islamic states propaganda videos is now
in fbi custody muhammad khalifa a former
toronto i.t worker was flown from syria
to virginia where he was charged with a
terror-related offense a u.s justice
department statement says through his
alleged leading role in translating
narrating and advancing isis's online
propaganda khalifa promoted the
terrorist group furthered its worldwide
recruitment efforts and expanded the
reach of videos that glorified the
horrific murders and indiscriminate
cruelty of isis the kurdish-led syrian
democratic forces captured him in early
2019. he was interviewed by global news
in syria later that year
prime minister justin trudeau has
disappointed indigenous communities
across the country by choosing to spend
the first ever national day for truth
and reconciliation vacationing on a
beach with his family on this week's
edition of the west block the national
chief of the assembly of first nations
chief roseanne archibald weighs in on
trudeau's decision to skip ceremonies
including one at the former residential
school site in kamloops our ottawa
bureau chief mercedes stephenson joins
us with a preview of that conversation
mercedes
the first national day for truth and
reconciliation was a chance for
canadians to confront the country's
colonial past one that saw indigenous
children pulled out of their mother's
arms forcibly sent to schools far away
designed to strip them of their identity
culture language even their names more
than 300 children have been found in
unmarked graves at former schools
they simply never came home
survivors say there are thousands more
graves out there waiting to be found and
on the somber day to mark the horrors of
the past prime minister justin trudeau
departed for a vacation with his family
in tofino this week on the west block
i'll sit down with the assembly of first
nations national chief roseanne
archibald who didn't mince her words on
the prime minister's decision to go on
vacation and where she felt he should
have been and it's not on a beach in
tofino what i would say is there are two
standing invitations from to kamloops to
schweitman to come to their community
which is the first site that we
recovered
215 of our little children
and i urge him to go and visit
cookie rosen casimir her council and her
community
and that would have been the ideal place
for him on
yesterday as we mark the very first
national day for truth and
reconciliation chief archibald will
reveal the challenges she says she's
encountering with the trudeau government
when it comes to moving forward with
truth and reconciliation we'll also talk
about systemic racism indigenous
canadians encounter in the health care
system now that the coroner's report
into the death of joyce eshequan has
been released in quebec national chief
archibald says many indigenous canadians
are afraid to seek out the care that
they need in the health care system and
that this has to change
many of our people
are afraid to go to hospitals and to see
medical professionals because they do
encounter overt
covert and systemic racism in the
healthcare system and that has to change
the health care system is about care
care is a key word there and another
word that we really need to start
utilizing more is love and care we'll
have more on the show tomorrow with
chief archibald
mercedes stephenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes
you're watching global national
here's a rare close up of mercury this
black and white image was captured
during the joint mission between the
european space agency and japan the
spacecraft had just completed the first
of six flybys using the planet's gravity
to slow down it's set to approach
mercury in december 2025 and stay for
two years
environmentalists are using a
revolutionary concept to preserve
precious ecosystems they're getting
legal standing for forests rivers and
lakes as if they're people it's happened
in other parts of the world but a river
in eastern quebec has become the first
in canada to have such a designation
global's christa hesse traveled there to
meet the people behind the magpie
river's new bill of rights
so this is magpie falls
the magpie river also known as moteheko
shibu in inu is known for its pristine
beauty and its rapids
danny pellet runs his white water
rafting company on the magpie this is a
world-class river
incredible nature really clean water
there aren't many places like this
left this region of quebec is famous for
its plentiful rivers many of which serve
as a source for the province's
hydroelectricity
when a hydroqueback project targeted the
magpie in 2009 paddlers
environmentalists the local government
and an inu first nation united to shield
this river from development
the alliance decided to try a new tactic
grant the river the same legal rights as
a person
in february two parallel resolutions
were passed by the inu council of
equanishi and the regional government of
mingani
they granted the river nine rights
including the right to flow and the
right to sue
colonialism
the inu of ikwaneshi have an ancestral
and spiritual connection with the river
and say it should be treated with
respect you know the rights of nature
you could say is a way to essentially
bring that indigenous value system
into western structures of law
over the last decade forests rivers and
lakes from new zealand to colombia have
been granted legal personhood rights
there's sort of this growing consensus
that environmental laws
are not enough to protect nature
the magpie river is the first ecosystem
in canada to be granted legal rights but
it likely won't be the last efforts to
assign rights to nature are underway in
at least five provinces and while the
river's bill of rights has not yet been
tried in court communities here hope
that it will be enough to deter future
development on the magpie
christa hesse global news mingani quebec
and you can see the full story on the
season premiere of the new reality
tonight at 7 right here on global
up next a new film linking canada's
residential schools with the foster care
system
festivities in halifax followed canada's
first national day of truth and
reconciliation hundreds of people came
out for a family day event hosted by the
migma native friendship center it was a
day full of indigenous history song and
dance volunteers show children how to
beat color feathers for dream catchers
and make sealed skin necklaces
in canada federal data shows more than
52 percent of children in foster care
are indigenous a new documentary shows
how that statistic is a result of
residential schools as jay durant
reports the film highlights the
generational trauma caused by the system
while celebrating indigenous resilience
all these kids that i paddle with we're
all kids in care so
we barely know who we are and we don't
know where we come from the new
documentary for love looks at the impact
of residential schools and indigenous
children in care
but layered throughout the film is a
message of hope that showcases the
strength of youth today and how they're
embracing their history everyone's
differences
are not overcome but they're celebrated
they deserve that they have the right to
know who they are their culture their
clan their tribe their language that's
their innate that's their inherent right
wyona sheldon and christine batash grew
up in the care system removed from an
abusive father when they were young just
felt really alone just didn't feel like
anything was going to be
better
it's a hot topic so but their story is a
resiliency and the love and the support
they've always had for each other
and about finally learning the truth
about where they came from we knew
nothing at all yeah
the chiefs they kind of looked at us and
they're like
who's your parents who's your
grandparents and i was just like uh so i
told them and then they're just like
you're in the wrong clan this is your
clan come here
four love looks at communities sharing
their culture rebuilding nations and
revitalizing language how do you
say
i love you
again again
that's where our oral traditions our
laws our myths our legends that's where
they're housed it's who we are and it's
in our dna
the batashas drove eight and a half
hours from prince george to vancouver to
be there for the premiere not knowing
entirely what to expect from the film
but knowing that they're proud to have
been able to share their story
we thought for the longest time that we
didn't have anybody who cared about us
and
now we know that we have a whole a whole
village that cares about us and loves us
jay durant global news
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill tonight
your canada is pinawa manitoba the
orange chair is a tribute to the
survivors and victims of canada's
residential schools we'd love to see
your corner of the country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]